hey at Troy York longtime troll Troy
York called in and left a voicemail at
two one nine to david p here's what he
had to say you are live fake news Donald
Trump was the reason the ttp went down
is in talking about early in the
campaign you are lying fake boobs ah the
coal industry is not dead and it needed
to provide jobs for people in those
communities okay all so that's it now
get still listen that's Troy York Troy
York is the guy who for years it or we
said he still on i know it sounded like
he stopped talking and the phone was
still on till date on with us yeah Troy
eric is a guy who for years was saying
I'm nuts to think that we're ever going
to have self-driving cars okay so I
wouldn't necessarily go by what Troy
York says is real and is not real the
coal industry is dying it is not dead
but it is dying the world is laughing at
us because we are trying we Trump is
trying to revitalize that industry and
by the way there are more solar jobs
being created there are more solar jobs
than coal jobs in the United States at
this point to say we are lying fake news
doesn't really mean anything Troy Troy
is interesting though because he seems
to hate the show a lot but he listens to
every episode he is a committed
antagonist you could say he's one of our
biggest fan in a way his in a way he is
on the bonus show today I want to talk
about the big announcement from YouTube
about YouTube TV fascinating fascinating
and also I've been waiting to go public
with this story we were almost scammed a
few months ago and I'm going to tell the
entire story I think it's a story you'll
find very very interesting okay on
today's bonus show david pakman.com
slash membership is how you sign up that
will give you instant access to the
bonus show there's a coupon code which
will give you a discount off of
membership that coupon code is i voted
17 i look forward to speaking with you
then